vsauce kevin here with two envelopes
one of them contains twice as much money
as the other one
and you get to choose which one you want
to take
but before you open your envelope and
find out whether you've won the smaller
prize or the larger prize
you have the opportunity to switch
to the other envelope so
do you do you switch
the answer is no irrefutably 100
no in our scenario it makes absolutely
no statistical difference
which envelope you choose each one could
contain the lower amount of money or the
higher amount of money with equal
probability and you have zero
information to help you choose one over
the other
right wrong the answer is irrefutably
one hundred percent switch
the envelopes and there's a mathematical
explanation for why
right wrong what is happening here
let's look let's
let's start at the beginning the origin
of the two
envelopes paradox is just as confusing
as the problem itself
in 1953 belgian mathematician maurice
kreichick posed a scenario in his book
about recreational mathematics in which
two men compared the values of neckties
their wives bought them
with neither man knowing the prices
also in 1953 a math book credits a
similar puzzle using playing cards to
physicist irwin schrodinger
ever hear of schrodinger's cat where a
cat in a box is both
alive and dead until you open the box
and
find out yeah same guy and in
our problem the forces at play are the
same whether we're using playing cards
neckties
or envelopes oh also i'm wearing my
brand new birthday paradox shirt i have
a
floating space baby bracketed by the
chart
detailing the probability of at least
two people sharing a birthday
versus the number of people it's in my
new vsauce2 store
link below wear it for all
the space children so
look the logic for not switching
envelopes is
pretty straightforward given that you
don't know anything about either one
or even what the higher and lower values
are inside them one is just as good
as the other but the math
in favor of switching is
kind of compelling let's say that the
envelope you choose contains
x dollars we don't know how much x
is just that there's something in the
envelope
we can call x the probability of that
envelope containing the smaller value is
one half and the probability of it
containing the larger amount is
is one half is fifty percent
the other envelope either contains twice
that amount
2x or half that amount
one half x if x turns out to be the
higher value then the other
envelope contains one half x if your
envelope x is the lower value then the
other envelope contains 2x
makes sense i've talked about expected
value in a few other
vsauce2 videos it's the average of the
possible
outcomes of a series of probabilistic
events
which we can use to identify the most
advantageous course
of action so to find the expected value
of the envelope we didn't choose
we add the value of the only two
possibilities weighted by their
probability
like this one over two times two x
plus one over two times one half
x equals five over
four x half of the time the other
envelope will contain
two x and half of the time the other
envelope will contain
one half x which equals an expected
value of
5 4 x
5 4 x is 25 more than
just x so our best possible choice is to
switch
to the other envelope cool
we did it but that makes no sense
you have a simple clean 50 50 chance of
choosing the envelope with more money
inside and
switching can't change that but the math
just told us that
it can don't worry though it gets
weirder what if i said you could switch
envelopes again if you wanted to
well then you just go through the same
process
over and over again always switching
never
opening forever and ever and ever and
erver and nerver
and blerver those aren't words but you
get the point
because switching makes the most
mathematical sense
with switching gaining you a 25
advantage and i just proved it
[Music]
so
let's come back to math later it's time
for logic
logician raymond smullion posed two
scenarios for the paradox
first the risk of gaining twice the
amount in your envelope is worthwhile
when the alternative is only losing
half of it you're gaining x or you're
only
losing half of x the potential payoff is
twice
as high as your risk of loss makes
perfect sense but one envelope contains
x and the other contains two x
so you're either gaining x or
losing x also
makes sense but both can't be true
so we're going to do this problem again
using economics professor
barry nailbuff's variation
let's say that we give an envelope to
player 1
and then flip a coin if it's heads we
put
double that amount in the second
envelope
and give it to player two if it's tails
we put
half that amount in the envelope and
give it to player two
neither player knows how much is in
their
envelope or the outcome of the coin toss
once they open their envelopes in secret
they can switch with each other if they
both agree
to switching player 1 opens their
envelope and finds
10 bucks with equal probability they
think that switching to player
2's envelope will get them 20 bucks
for a 10 gain or take them down to
5 bucks for a 5 loss
player 1 decides to switch because
switching gives them
a greater possible reward relative to
what they might
lose player two who's in another room
opens their envelope and finds five
bucks
they think there's a fifty percent
chance that switching to player one's
envelope will get them
ten bucks for a five dollar game or get
them only
two dollars and fifty cents for a two
dollars and fifty cent
loss so player two also thinks that what
they stand to gain
is greater than what they might lose
they are
absolutely sure that their upside is
better than their downside but
it's obvious that both players can't
have an advantage
in this game that's impossible
if you're confused at this point
good martin gardner one of history's
greatest puzzle solvers and paradox
explainers knew the answer but admitted
that there just wasn't a simple way to
communicate
the flaw in mathematical reasoning
and sadly that's where our journey
ends no it's not because we can
figure this out think of it this way
the total sum of money in the envelopes
is three units a small unit and then a
larger value that's made
up of two smalls that combine
to form a total of x
if you've got the smaller envelope its
value
is x over three and if you have the
larger envelope its value is two
x over three when you switch
from small to large you gain x
over three and when you switch from
large to
small you lose x over three
so the expected value of switching is
one half times two x minus x
over three plus one half times
x minus two x over three
which equals zero
there's just no value in switching it
doesn't help us
and it doesn't hurt us which is probably
what you
knew until we got math involved the
two envelopes problem is a lot more than
just
x and 2x which is what makes it
a falsitical paradox because
there appears to be a gain from
switching when we fail to consider that
the states of the two envelopes
don't actually reflect simple values of
x and 2x a 2x
envelope is only 2x when it's the larger
amount
and the one half x envelope is only
one half x when it's the smaller amount
without recognizing that difference
basic algebra playing off our common
sense
fools us into thinking that each switch
gives you a gain of 5 over 4
or 25 it's really a matter of
perspective depending on which envelope
you're holding which one you
think you have which one you think you
don't have and
which one you want to wind up with your
course of action might be
incredibly clear or not
and then clear again and then not
again until you realize that
no matter if you diagnose it
mathematically no matter if you
deconstruct it logically no matter what
you
do when it comes to the two envelope
paradox you were right
all along and as always
[Music]
thanks for watching
[Music]